hello everyone I'm Jordan and I'm joined
by max hey guys and we're here to talk
about apex legends season 3 which max
got a behind-the-scenes look at during a
preview event I am incredibly jealous
because I'm a huge titanfall and apex
legends fan and I wish I could have gone
couldn't go so I'm here to [ __ ] you
about it and have you tell me what you
saw this was the most content packed
season I've seen so far I can safely say
pretty much everything has changed the
map has changed too there's a new legend
there's an entirely new meta with the
guns and the legends themselves there's
new game mechanics there's a new weapon
as well there's just so much content
packed into this I say this probably has
more content than one and two combined
maybe the fact that you even mentioned
that we're getting a new map at all like
season 2 only introduced like it was a
substantial map change but that was
pretty much all it was we were still in
Kings Canyon but now we're getting a
whole new map world's edge so you got to
try it like what's the difference like
is it the same size like is there
similar environmental hazards like
what's the deal with it there's so many
different mechanics in this map compared
to Kings Canyon there's lava which
damages you there's like water Springs
which I launched you up and balloon you
just like a jump Tower would there's a
golden vault where it's like a secret
key I never found it
they get like just massive amounts of
epic gold purple loot it's kind of hard
to gauge it right now I'm sure there
will be a clear number at some point but
it seems like it's at least two to three
times larger than Kings Canyon but can
we land on the Train I want to know
about the Train oh yes yes there's
multiple ways to land on the Train
actually so you can either just fly in
on it you can wait for it to stop and
jump in on it there's also zip lines
that go over it so you can kind of
zipline onto them there's one clip that
I had where I was trying to catch up to
it on the very back I was slowing down
it felt like a wild west movie or like
trying to catch it to the caboose
it was really cool there's so many
stories that it's gonna come out of this
map that when players jump in and play
that don't be able to share and to kind
of help us explore this new map were
finally finally getting a new recon
character bloodhound is no longer the
only recon Legend now we have crypto so
you actually got to try them what are
his abilities what's he's like so he has
his drone which is a tactical ability he
deploys it any stationary he just
controls a drone by itself it flies
around and pings
means it opens boxes it opens doors and
it also has the ultimate which is the
EMP which is a massive blast rate as it
goes through walls and buildings - so
this is a complete sphere radius that
the stuns enemies and those 50 shield
damage and destroys all traps so it's a
great great automate actually his
passive is his pinging with drone that
information is relayed to your teammates
just like bloodhounds would he's
definitely an interesting character to
try out for sure awesome I know that
you're gonna be doing a full breakdown
of his ability so if someone's at least
interested in buying crypto they can at
least watch that video to get a general
idea of how each of those abilities work
and how they can kind of pair and
counter some of the other legends in the
game so you also mentioned that we are
getting a new weapon and we've known
about this for a while it's the charge
rifle which was a Titan killing weapon
and titanfall and titanfall - and now
it's being used in an infantry sense in
the apex game so does it behave exactly
like its second fall counterpart or it's
a little different I'm not the best
person to ask for that cuz I never
played Titan fault I should have played
titanfall but I can safely say that
definitely halo 3 and the Spartan laser
is very similar to this gun it has an
initial charge line which actually does
damage enemies and then it does a final
shot first shot which does a pretty good
amount of damage it's a fairly good
weapon it's not a crate weapon so you
can pick it up off the ground like a
regular lube pool weapon which is great
because we don't have to go hunting
around for that weapon now there just be
anywhere in the map I say it's kind of
like the havoc it's just a weapon that
you just are gonna find now on this new
map yeah and it's my it's very good on
ammo too so it's very easy to use some
of the other weapons that we've
previously used they've also now changed
just because their hop-up their guns at
disruptor ammo is gone and the skull
piercer is gone which kind of dampens
you of the effects of guns like the re
45 and the wingman but we're getting new
hop ups now - that are gonna transform
previous old guns in brand new way so
what do they do
so the double tap trigger goes on the g7
Scout
the Eva 8 Auto shotgun both of these get
the ability to shoot two shots really
quickly successively after another one
trigger pull there's also an anvil
receiver hop-up which is new for the the
300 was the first time there's a hop-up
for 301 and the flatline as well so you
have to change the fire mode to
semi-automatic for both these weapons
for the hop-up to work and it does just
a massive amount of damage so because of
these new hop ups removed and added the
weapon meta has just changed so much
previously strong weapons are now much
weaker and weapons that you normally
would not use are now very strong so we
have a new map we have a new legend we
have a new gun we have old guns now
performing in new ways are there any
other like new mechanics like coming in
season 3 yes there is there's even more
gameplay mechanics as well there are new
voice lines that the legends were given
to warn you when you are getting a third
party which is amazing and this mechanic
can give you the edge when you're
getting attacked by to the party
and that's great information if you want
to get out of a situation where there's
just too many enemies or if you don't
know if the enemies that you're shooting
at or with each other it's it clears
that information up to tell you like
okay this is a hectic situation there's
more than one squads we want to keep you
want to stay in the fight or do you want
to get out
there's also another mechanic of clips
which also lets you kind of trash talk
in the game you think you're not being
watched right now don't be an idiot and
enemies can hear this so you now you can
trash talk through your legend at other
enemies which is totally cool it's
another like social aspect to this which
is great and possibly tactical to which
you can like distract enemies like you
said there's a lot of new stuff coming
in season three but there are some
things about season two that we really
enjoyed here at games but like I really
liked the limited time events when
Wraith and octane took over the arena
can we expect more of those limited time
events in the future with season three
so they did tease some sort of Halloween
event so a little teaser of Gibraltar
being spooky in the dark which is kind
of weird but it's very fitting for
something that come in October which is
a Halloween time source expecting
something in late October for a special
event also a new ranked mode is gonna be
in play people are gonna be dropping one
and a half tears and the RP system is
gonna be changed tremendously it's going
to be very heavy penalties for people
who leave in the middle of the game and
a much higher RP gain for every win and
every kill they get now these are
massive changes for an already pretty
awesome game but like it's gonna be
interesting literally everything in this
game is changing which is just awesome
they didn't expect this massive upsurge
when the game first came out and they've
been kind of spinning their wheels for a
bit to like try to catch up to the
content I think this season they finally
got their traction and they're just
pumping out a whole bunch of new stuff
which is great well thank you max that
was season 3 for apex legend some of the
new stuff that you can't expect for
getting a new map we're getting a new
legend we're getting a new weapon we're
getting new buffs and debuffs new hop-up
we're getting a whole bunch of new stuff
so be on the lookout for our coverage of
apex legends season 3 as the season
continues to evolve and we experience
more
supposedly limited time events like this
apparent Halloween event we'll also be
covering a few other games like destiny
- shadow keep which is getting its
expansion released on the same day as
apex legends season 3 so that'll be fun
bye bye
[Music]
you